be sure to follow me on instagram there
you can hang out with me and talk to me
directly
okay so we are getting back into the
boys and and much like we did with the
first video the uncensored one is gonna
go up on patreon right the one that we
make public on YouTube for though for
all the world to see is gonna be the
censored version and a lot of that's
really just kind of maintain the family
friendly format that we have on the
channel releases family-friendly as we
can get and and then you know allowing
the the more non family-friendly
elements to its or just be broadcast out
there for the world to see right I
figured a credit card was a pretty good
line of judgment there right I mean
parents if your kids get ahold of your
credit card that's that's really more
your problem than it is mine
so nonetheless uh you know getting into
this it's a cool concept because what it
does is it initially picks up with the
character of starlight now this is one
of the more controversial moments in the
story and the reason why is because
starlight hails from a group called the
young Americans now in the boys there's
two main groups out there at least when
it comes to the younger kids right
there's the teenage kicks and then the G
young Americans the young Americans are
are almost kinda like the young
Republicans right they're like really
more of a conservative group really
hailing from from various places but for
the most part see me to kind of be ha at
least entrenched largely in kind of the
Heartland America sort of sort of
landscape and then you go on to the th
kicks which are more generation action
we'll talk more about them you know once
once we get to that portion of the story
but for Starlights character she's
really young she's wide-eyed pretty
conservative right so she was never
really like really active out there in
terms of being more liberal with her own
you know her own body and and the kind
of things that go with it and so her as
a character had always wanted to join
the seven it's one of these things worse
almost kind of like she'd been raised to
believe the seven is what you want right
like it's the inside of the inside it
indeed it makes sense the way the Garth
Ennis writes this the the seven is kind
of allegory for like the Justice League
more so than anything else but you can
also kind of attribute things like The
Avengers to it you know kind of the
creme de la creme of the superhero
community as it was one of these things
where if you've made it into the seventh
then you've officially made it in the
superhero landscape right like you're in
it to win it and so when when she looks
at carrot is like home Lander and other
members of the seven she really idolizes
them and that's why it's a pretty huge
shock to her character when suddenly
she's basically asked to commit an act
that's pretty extreme here now as I was
kind of crazy because following up with
a character of Huey this goes into
basically him being brought to America
writing this what are these funny things
where when he gets here he basically
ends up getting a hotel in the South
Bronx which is like one of the crappiest
places ever in the history of the world
and it's like like he has no idea what
he was getting into you right like he
just looked up the classifieds and they
were like it's a cheap place basically
it was a really affordable place to stay
and it's like yeah man just because it's
the South Bronx like you're living with
a bunch of meth heads and coke dealers
oh yeah of course it's gonna be cheap
like of course is gonna be a cheap place
to live but him being brought here is
basically for him to be introduced to
the rest of the team right to the rest
of the boys - Frenchie - mother's milk
and to the girl it's kind of cool
because what this does is it goes into
Billy butcher basically giving him this
explanation and kind of saying look this
is not gonna be like last time and the
way that he explains this really seems
to indicate that the last time a team
was together there wasn't really a whole
lot of red tape so much as there were a
lot of rules they had to follow right
like they basically felt kind of under
the purview of some organization most
likely we can assume the CIA just
because of the fact that he worked with
the predecessor to uh Susan rayner who
currently runs it but basically there
was a lot of red tape it was like
there's there's things that you can and
can't do you got to follow the rules all
I kind of stuff instead they're
basically operating now under like the
presidential purview meaning that they
don't answer to any of the intelligence
organizations out there right they don't
answer to the CIA the NSA the FBI any
unidentified agencies that are out there
they'll answer to them they answer
directly to the President of the United
States and they're basically given
leniency which means they can tap phones
they can do whatever it is they need to
do and operate outside of the law now
under any normal circumstance this would
be considered insane right it's like
Gestapo tactics stuff right having some
kind of covert organization that exists
out there and it's one of these things
where where it's it's intriguing because
people's perception of it really kind of
waxes and wanes based on how they feel
right I mean you like these guys are
targeting superheroes who are clearly
abusing their power but if they decided
to target people well then it becomes a
problem and so it's one of these things
where the act itself isn't really the
problem
it's how they use it that's the problem
right that's really kind of what the
argument comes down to at the end of the
day and so that's why it's it's it's
really intriguing here because it's
basically like we can do anything that
we need to do in order to bring these
guys down a peg and so what he says is
the first we're gonna do is we're gonna
send a message we're gonna let these
guys know that we're back in business
and this is kind of a cool thing because
unlike the TV show which really seemed
to hit at the idea that homeland or
didn't know who Billy butcher was
outside of the fact that like he worked
with the company at one point and Billy
butcher's wife was like this social
media chick for it for home Lander it
wasn't as if he had operated before you
know as from the TV show from what we
can tell at least on what I've seen the
boys are the boys and there that is kind
of like they're basically in business
now and so it's it's intriguing you know
at least in their interactions with the
the other superheroes that are there but
what it does here is it jumps over just
one of the character of Starlite after
she
finish this deed and again where you
would kind of look at this and you would
expect like some solidarity right from
Queen made you know this idea that like
there's another woman there and the fact
that you know that that that starlight
have been forced to commit this you know
terrible act what if the very least sort
of come with some kind of you know
condolence from from Queen Maeve yeah
yeah it sucks you know it blows balls
but basically you kind of have to you
got to play the game instead she's met
with hostility right like we may be just
kinda like yeah yeah whatever who cares
like that's the way the game gets played
sorry about your luck take your sad
songs and you're trying elsewhere I've
got better things to do than to listen
to you like it's very hardcore and it's
very ruthless and so what this does is
it really kind of shows that unlike
superhero themes that we would
traditionally believe them be right in
the sense of like superheroes working
together and looking out for the other's
best interests and different things like
that it is really kind of every man for
themselves and and all the people here
are really just kind of bad people at
their core rightly this really kind of
seems to be crappy human beings now this
seems to be more circumstantial than
anything else insofar as they probably
started out as good people somewhere
along the line what kind of see how that
plays out as a story progresses but then
along the way they just kind of became
corrupted and screwed up by the fact
that they really didn't have to answer
to anybody and so as time progressed
they just sort of ended up in their
their current form and so from here
again we jump back to building butcher
and this was really when the plan gets
made right because they're going after
the teenage kicks and what they
basically say here is that as far as the
teenage kicks are concerned to the
general public they're kind of edgy and
they're sort of you know this
devil-may-care kind of reckless attitude
or for the most part they're good kids
who are basically trying to prove
themselves and one day join the second
right I mean that's really kind of what
they're shooting for you know but the
reality of this is that as Willie
butcher as Billy butcher explains to him
it's anything but right like the
public's perception of teenage kicks is
nothing like what they're actually like
the teenage kicks are totally screwed up
in some of the worst ways as that's when
things get kind of crazy because from
there he basically switch over to
homeland or in a train now the reality
was that they kind of had this basic you
know meaning more or less you know and
of course somebody from Vaught was
basically their meeting they referred to
them as the money the means by which the
seven are able to operate the way they
are you know with their satellite up in
the sky and it's really were like all
the brand deals more or less come from
but basically in this meeting a train
had made some pretty crude gestures
toward toward star like kind of mocking
her for the deed she was forced to
perform and as a result of that homeland
her freaks out now here's the crazy
thing about this is you would look at
this and you would say hey you would
hope the
moths will be yes we asked her to do a
terrible thing but like we're not gonna
throw it in front of her face no there's
no concern for how it impacted starlight
whatsoever it's you made a crew gesture
and you made us look bad in front of the
money do not make us look bad in front
of the money money is what matters money
is the only important thing here
everything else in this world is
secondary and it's kind of crazy because
it's a it's it's a super-selfish but
also kind of careless attitude right
like removed from his own humanity and
that's what's so crazy about this is it
just kind of like that's what we're
dealing with with this character right
usually like rude threats threatening to
basically shoot a train in the face with
us with his heat vision and more or less
and just saying like if this happens
again I'm gonna break you apart I'm
gonna send you back to the teenage kicks
and you're gonna stay there forever
right for the rest of your days and as
it's pretty intense and it's pretty cool
because from there you basically end up
having like all this footage this
gathered together at the hands of Hugh
who's the one that's doing all this
surveillance this idea that like
different members of teenage kicks are
sleeping with each other is they engage
in such reckless and and really like
crude behavior right like dealing with
things like drugs this kind of behavior
is not what the team is known for and
that's what the boys are banking on
because what they do is they take all
this information and they basically use
it as a means to blackmail them but
something that I want to talk about here
is you basically deal with the
introduction of compound V now in the TV
show the advent are really the
introduction of compound V this
substance this kind of drug that's being
used it's one of these things were it's
it's kind of like discovered over the
course of the show what this is done of
what what's really kind of given to us
here is that Billy butcher knows about
it he's just kinda like yeah man like
this is compound V like if you take it
in its most pure form the effects are
permanent and you basically develop
powers if you take it in basically a
chopped down form then the effects are
only temporary and this is kind of a big
deal because him being able to get his
hands on this is somewhat of an isolated
thing but it's one of these scenarios
where it's like if this became available
to the general public
you'd have powers everywhere by like
you'd be like the hottest drug on the
market which indeed it is in a way but
it's pretty interesting with regards to
that sort of introduction here because
what you end up having is huy injected
with compound V which grants him like a
few days worth of essentially just
powered super-strength or different
abilities and so the reason why he was
given this is because following this
particular action you know this idea of
blackmailing the members of teenage
kicks Billy butcher knows that things
are gonna come to blows and this is kind
of an important thing because what this
basically means is he's prepared for a
fight meaning he went into this knowing
they were going to be consequences and
sacrifices were gonna be made so it's
one of these things were Billy butcher
didn't go into it
kind of wide-eyed like let's see what
happens hopefully we can defeat these
guys he went into it going for blood
right and we'll actually find out the
reason why here in a little while but
from there you jumped a Huey who
basically thought about leaving you know
leaving the United States but ultimately
stayed here and ends up talking to
starlight now this is a huge moment here
is probably one of the most important
moments in the early part of the story
because what this does is it kind of
confirms what we already knew that star
lights is not an inherently bad
character right now this is kind of the
stance that Garth Ennis seems to take
here is that in the beginning it seemed
like a lot of these characters were not
inherently bad people they maybe started
out like starlight you know again we'll
find out as a story goes on but at the
moment with what was what's going on
here if starlet was given enough time
and remained on the team in its current
form and and ran it to its conclusion
stayed there for a long enough amount of
time she'd be screwed up just like
everybody else where I should be screwed
up just like they are but ultimately her
talking to Huey kind of grants this
moment of reprieve because the two of
them both talk and you'll kind of talk
about these jobs they have right you
know he doesn't really reveal I'm
working for Billy butcher and we're
looking to bring down superheroes but
it's one of these things worse like I'm
working a job it really changes the way
that I see the world and I don't know if
I can handle it and for Annie it's the
exact same way because now Annie's
having an existential crisis right like
there's the world as she knew it right
she was on the young Americans who were
teenage superheroes in training so that
one day they could go on and prove
themselves and become a part of the
seven this kind of fantasy she'd been
living her entire life and it finally
managed to achieve it only to find out
that nothing was what she thought it was
and so now she's kind of questioning her
place in all of this like should I go on
and continue being a superhero is what I
did worth what it takes to see what
happens to see if I can actually have a
positive impact you know to see if I can
go into this place and in turn like try
to fix it and try to make it better try
to take us to what we're supposed to be
these are all the kind of things that
she's basically mulling over in her head
and the result is that they kind of have
this sort of party not really knowing
who the other is what are the very least
walking away with somewhat of a better
understanding well I don't know they're
not the only ones struggling out there
with these various assignments they have
to deal with now at this point this is
when it gets into blackmailing the
members of teenage kicks right because
what is up happening is with this
information thrown out there what Billy
butcher had basically done I'll albeit
not made public we're really given to
the team is we know what you guys are
doing like we're aware of what it is
that you guys are doing we're aware that
all the actions you guys engage in for
the most part are completely
contradictory to how the public
perceives you and if you guys don't
sacrifice one of your members then we're
gonna make all this information public
and so what you have are the teenage
kicks basically freaking out
asking the questions who in the world
sent this you know who knows about us
and all the stuff that we've been doing
and at the same time basically saying
like which one are we gonna sacrifice
because you would look at that and you
would say okay well maybe it's in the
best interest or maybe they'd like these
various prostitutes they were with they
could dump the information but the issue
is that you're running a pretty
dangerous scheme there because you're
dealing with guys who have superpowers
and to question these various you know
women of the night would have to ask
themselves is it worth putting my life
on the line to expose these guys for
what it is that they're doing and if I
did what would I gain like if I if I'm
looking for like fame or notoriety that
puts me on the map right it puts a giant
target on my back if I'm looking for
money that money can be traced unless
it's like unmarked bills or something
like that there's a way for these folks
to find me so there's really no
incentive there for them to do that and
they get paid pretty well so long as
they can handle the job there's really
no reason for them to kind of step out
there and so it really kind of comes
down to billion them to basically say
we're gonna wear this we're gonna make
our first move we're gonna make our
strike right we're gonna basically force
these guys to essentially dump one of
their members out there you know to
basically sacrifice one of their members
and that's when the questions asked who
are we gonna sacrifice who we're gonna
give up and ultimately they end up
settling on shout out and it's one of
the controversial controversial moments
because shout out is a black guy and
he's gay and so was one of these things
for them to come out and say he's a gay
black guy you know and so this is
something that we didn't really want to
bring out to the world we didn't really
want to make public because of the fact
of how the world sees us but for the
most part like we feel like shout out
should be allowed to be himself as it
was kind of crazy because while that
huge press conference is going on
homeland is basically looking around and
he's saying this seems exactly like him
this seems like Billy butcher this seems
like something he would do so again the
two of them have history here and it's
intriguing because when Billy butcher
seems to have operated before it seemed
to very much be subterfuge right
espionage different things like that
going in using really sneaky tactics to
achieve a particular goal it seems to
really be his hauling card more or less
and so the fact that that that homeland
er seems to know that this is Billy
butcher indicates that of course now the
question is who do we basically dump out
here right like how do we basically
inform these guys of what's going on and
so what this does is it leads to a
direct conflict between the boys and
between the teenage kicks and the
teenage kicks kind of go into it
reckless right and that's one of the big
differences between the teenage kicks
and the seven the seven seem a little
more reserved but a little more willing
to do their research a little more
willing to poke around and say what are
these guys capable of the issue is that
we're home Lander and the members of the
seven are familiar with Billy butcher
and the tactics he uses the teenage
kicks are not so they basically go
flying into the
thing blind as far as they're concerned
it's a handful of disgruntled people who
were angry with superheroes for some
reason or another and in turn like
wanted to somehow frame or find some way
to basically force the teenage kicks to
dump one of their own what they get when
they get into this conflict is anything
but they basically end up coming face to
face with guys who one have consumed
compound V to basically give themselves
abilities and to are well trained in
hand-to-hand combat and various
abilities to take these guys out and
that's one of the things that Billy
butcher had really talked to Huy about
Billy butcher had talked to Huy and
saying none of these guys are trained
they're given abilities then they go out
there and it or they least say they have
abilities and they go out there and they
go on to become whatever it is they're
gonna become sometimes villains
sometimes heroes whatever the case may
be but these are basically young kids
who are just running out there with
abilities and just fighting and because
they're not trained they are no match
for the forces of Billy butcher and the
voice and so ultimately they basically
have their backsides handed to them in
no uncertain terms right now one of the
other big things that happens here is
one of them actually gets crushed in the
stomach by Huy and a moment of panic and
that's one of the things that was not
supposed to happen because they weren't
supposed to start killing them they were
supposed to use tactics to basically
force them to commit a series of acts or
or to reveal information they wouldn't
normally want to reveal staying kind of
underhanded staying staying very
cloaking dagger and so with one of them
having having been killed what this
means is the boys struck first right let
the boys made their move they struck
first and they killed one of the
superheroes and so what this means is
that going forward now it's basically
gloves off now it's like we can
essentially do whatever we want to do
right like we can we can take these guys
out with extreme prejudice now again
this was within the Charter of what the
boys were able to do it just wasn't
really supposed to happen so soon and so
this is kind of gonna gonna be taken as
a personal affront by the members of the
Senate and in turn they're going to
they're gonna respond accordingly and so
as a result of that you kind of have
this moment where mothers milk almost
you know really kind of talks to or
really sort of talks to billy butcher
and says a man have you ever wondered if
like there were any superheroes out
there who were not inherently bad guys
this is very important because what it
does is it shows like the lack of
concern from billy butcher right like
you know he basically says like do you
believe any of these guys out there are
not bad guys so they're good guys
they're trying to do good things and the
responsibility is maybe but if they are
screwing they're gonna they're gonna go
anyway so it's just one of these things
where he has an outright hatred of the
various superheroes who are out there
and the reason why is is as he explains
it to Huey it really is is rooted in the
fact
that his wife was sexually assaulted by
one of the superhero she was knocked up
and the result was that she essentially
had become pregnant and interned like
some superhuman you know fetus whatever
this had ripped itself out of her and so
this is what it seems to be from from
this point right now the basis behind
why Billy butcher does what he does is
because he has a straight-up vendetta
against one of these guys now he doesn't
quite come out and say it but the
implication based on on the comic as
well as what we've seen in the show I
thought it was homeland er you know the
one who ended up causing this so that's
really kind of the guy he's going after
the the top guy here but again it's
really intriguing and it's a it's a
really really good story and it's pretty
saw the way is progressing so forth but
we got being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to comments explained make sure you guys
at the sub button to become part of the
rock core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]